[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
metry Siri Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend im Sport hat Norbert später
noch mal den Blick auf einen Top-Spiel
in der Europa Leverkusen steht im
Halbfinale schon genannt dann schauen
wir jetzt gemeinsam auf die Themen an
diesem Freitag
Krieg der Logistik der Westen will die
Ukraine gegen Russland verstärkt mit
Munition und Ersatzteilen unterstützen
wieder gewählt mit 88 Prozent der
FDP-Bundesparteitag bestätigt Christian
Lindner in seinem Amt als Parteichef
nichts ging mehr die Eisenbahner
Gewerkschaft macht mit dem bundesweiten
Streik Druck vor den Tarifverhandlungen
in der kommenden Woche
[Musik]
eine ukrainische Großoffensive wird ja
erwartet vielleicht häufen sich auch
deshalb die internationalen
Unterstützungsaktionen für Kiew wie zum
Beispiel in Ramstein wo heute
US-Verteidigungsminister Austin mit
seinen Verbündeten über weitere
Militärhilfen beraten hat eine drängende
Frage auch für Nato-Generalsekretär
Stoltenberg der gerade in Kiefer über
die Ergebnisse des ramstein-treffens
informiert Ulf Roller
lass uns in die Kameras schauen sagt der
deutsche Verteidigungsminister mit einem
Lächeln antwortet sein ukrainischer
Kollege eine gemeinsame Unterschrift der
sogenannten Leopard Panzer Koalition
unter anderem aus Deutschland und Polen
sie will bis mein Polen ein gemeinsames
wartungszentrum für Kampfpanzer
einrichten
es ist sehr sehr wichtig dass wir die
gelieferten Waffen auch warten wir
müssen sie reparieren und in standhalten
der Leopard ist im Anmarsch und dieser
Traum ist wahr geworden
Aufnahmen vor wenigen Tagen vom
ukrainischen Grenzschutz zur Verfügung
gestellt zeigen die totale Zerstörung
bachmuts
alle hier in Ramstein stellen sich auf
einen langen Krieg ein
die Alliierten steigern gerade ihre
Waffenproduktion Deutschland die USA und
die anderen arbeiten eng mit der
Rüstungsindustrie zusammen um mehr
Munition zu produzieren
Amerika hat weitere Militärhilfen für
die Ukraine im Wert von rund 300
Millionen Dollar zugesagt in einem
Interview mit dem heute journal bedankte
sich der ukrainische
Verteidigungsminister für die Hilfe
forderte aber noch mehr Waffen
selbstverständlich reichen diese
Lieferungen nicht aus und Sie werden
auch nie ausreichen deshalb haben wir
heute neue munitionsbestellungen
angestoßen
die Ukraine steht vor kurz vor einer
Frühjahrsoffensive sie braucht schnell
Munition so wollen dass die Unterstützer
erreichen indem wir alle noch mal in
unsere Bestände schauen und gucken was
wir zur Verfügung stellen können indem
wir einkaufen wenn man so wie man das so
schön sagt in der ganzen Welt und
zusammen zu bekommen was zusammen
bekommen ist der Krieg in der Ukraine er
wird auch eine Materialschlacht
gehen wir jetzt nach Brüssel zu Florian
neu an Florian also aus Rammstein ein
erneuertes Versprechen der Militärhilfe
im Fokus Ersatzteile und Munition wie
weit ist man da eigentlich schon
zumindest der Europa die EU braucht
weiterhin ihre Zeit um mal ein konkretes
Beispiel zu berichten vor genau einem
Monat hat die EU sich hier geeinigt dass
sie innerhalb eines Jahres eine Million
Geschosse an die Ukrainer liefern will
und die auch gemeinsam einkaufen möchte
und es hat einen Monat her man sich
seitdem nur zerstritten wie man das
ganze umsetzt frankreich will dass man
diese Geschosse nur in Europa kauft die
meisten anderen EU-Staaten sagen
hauptsache man kauft jetzt wenn nötig
eben auch im Rest der Welt und darüber
sind jetzt eben vier Wochen vergangen
ohne ein einziges Geschoss zu kaufen
viele Diplomaten haben mir heute gesagt
dass sei wirklich peinlich für Europa
ist zeigt einfach dass die Zeitrechnung
hier weiterhin eine andere ist als die
die für die Ukraine und ihre geplante
Frühjahrsoffensive eigentlich von Nöten
wäre immerhin kleiner positiver
Lichtblick am Ende ein Diplomat sagt man
sei jetzt auf dem Weg zu einer Einigung
danke nach Brüssel Florian
entlang der über 1.000 Kilometer langen
Frontlinie bereitet sich das ukrainische
Militär schon länger auf eine erwartete
Offensive vor seit Tagen mehren sich
Spekulationen wie und wann immer dieser
Gegenangriff auf die russischen
Stellungen erfolgt dafür werden sehr
viele Soldaten benötigt bis auf wenige
Ausnahmen sind alle Männer zwischen 18
und 65 wehrpflichtig und natürlich das
zeigt daran Hassan Sade ist es auch von
engsten und Sorgen begleitet die Ukraine
braucht Soldaten in Odessa mobilisiert
die Armee auf der Straße Einsatz
Besprechung Alexander leitet die Gruppe
im Fokus sind erfahrene gut ausgebildete
Männer der Wirtschaftsjurist wurde
letztes Jahr selbst ein berufen
sucht adäquate motivierte Menschen keine
antisozialen Personen oft entstammen sie
der Mittelschicht sie müssen gesund sein
und sollen fachlich weitergebildet oder
von höherer Bildung sein
die Anforderungen an Rekruten steigen
auch aufgrund von moderner westlicher
Militärtechnik dieser Mann passt ins
Raster Aufnahme der Personalien sehr hi
selbstständig muss sich jetzt innerhalb
der nächsten 7 Tage im Rekrutierungsbüro
melden erst dort wird über seine
Einberufung entschieden
die Armee mit Geld zu unterstützen ist
eine Sache aber ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob ich einen anderen Menschen töten kann
psychologisch bin ich darauf nicht
vorbereitet
ein Recht auf Kriegsdienst Verweigerung
gibt es nicht mit der Unterschrift rückt
die Front für ihn näher
ich denke an meine Familie ich bin
Alleinverdiener ich weiß nicht wie sie
ohne mich auskommen sollen
die ukrainische am Meer leidet Verluste
Frontsoldaten benötigen Kampfpausen nur
freiwillige zu mobilisieren reicht nicht
mehr aus auch wegen der bevorstehenden
großoffiziere
jetzt nach Russland dort wurde die
Großstadt belgor dort am Abend von einer
Explosion erschüttert ein Kampfjet habe
ungeplanten Munitionen abgeschossen so
dass russische Verteidigungsministerium
die Munition landete am Rande einer
Hauptstraße und explodierte kurz nach
dem Aufpreis ein etwa 20 m großer Krater
blieb zurück auch umliegende Wohnhäuser
und Autos wurden beschädigt drei
Menschen sollen verletzt worden sein
zur Unterstützung der Ukraine gibt es
unter anderem wieder aktuelle Zahlen im
ZDF Politbarometer Matthias hornoff ist
im Studio schön guten Abend was denken
denn die Befragten darüber naja weitere
Militärhilfen die finden breite
Zustimmung der Westen sollte die Ukraine
noch stärker militärisch unterstützen
finden 28 %. 45% sprechen sich für eine
unveränderte Unterstützung aus 22%
wollen weniger helfen eine stärkere
Unterstützung wünschen sich vor allem
die Anhänger von Grünen und SPD ist ein
baldiges Kriegsende in Sicht
11% glauben das ist in den nächsten
Monaten Verhandlungen zur Beendigung des
Krieges geben wird eine sehr große
Mehrheit von 87 Prozent erwartet das
nicht Matthias dann schauen wir jetzt
auf die politische Stimmung im Land was
was tut sich da das gibt jedenfalls
Bewegungen im Kräfteverhältnis der
Parteien wenn am Sonntag Bundestagswahl
wäre können wir die SPD auf 18 Prozent
minus 1 im Vergleich zu Ende März
cdu/csu 31 plus 1 grüne 18 + 1
fdp6-1 AFD 15 linke 4 - 1
die Ampel hätte damit keine Mehrheit
wohl aber schwarz rot und schwarz grün
die FDP mit leichten Verlusten wie wird
Parteichef Lindner gesehen Christian
nennt nach wird die FDP erfolgreich
führen sagen 40 Prozent aller Befragten
49% zweifeln daran aber
82% der FDP-Anhänger Glauben an den
Erfolg mit Lindner so viel von
Politbarometer interessante Zahlen und
davon gibt es sehr viel mehr vielen Dank
Matthias das komplette ZDF
Politbarometer wie immer heute Abend ab
22 Uhr im heute journal oder jederzeit
auch in unserer ZDF heute App
mit 88 Prozent ist FDP-Chef Lindner vor
zwei Stunden vom Bundesparteitag in
Berlin wiedergewählt worden nach zuletzt
verlorenen Landtagswahlen und
ausbleibenden Höhenflügen bei den
Zustimmungswerten geht es den Liberalen
vor allem um Profilschärfung bei Themen
wie Wirtschaft und soliden Finanzen
Frankfurt
ein paar Prozent weniger trotzdem ein
Traumergebnis 88% für Christian Lindner
der FDP-Chef unangefochten an der Spitze
zuvor ein Appell für die
Eigenständigkeit der Liberalen in der
Koalition bei Klimaschutz Mobilität
Bildung vor allem aber für eine
nachhaltige Finanzpolitik auch im
Interesse künftiger Generationen
aus diesem Grund liebe Freundinnen und
Freunde ist das Festhalten an der
Schuldenbremse nicht irgendein Fetisch
es ist noch nicht einmal nur ein Befehl
der Verfassung es ist ein Gebot der
ökonomischen Klugheit dass wir nicht
weiter auf Kosten der Zukunft Wirtschaft
schaffen die FDP sieht sich als Stimme
der Vernunft in einer unruhigen
Koalition für Lindners neuen Kurs steht
auch Bettina stark Watzinger die
Bildungsministerin rückt als Vize in die
Parteispitze auf natürlich ist eine
Regierungskoalition Kompromiss schließen
und
in den letzten Wochen gab es ja auch
viele Stunden die man zusammengesessen
ist aber wenn am Ende etwas Gutes dabei
herauskommt dann ist es jede Minute Wert
vor der Halle ein paar Demonstranten
Umweltverbände sie richten sich vor
allem gegen die Politik des
Verkehrsministers Volker wissinghaber
kontert
keiner von uns muss sich von den
klima-demonstranten dort draußen
Vorwürfe machen lassen weil wir in
Wahrheit nicht nur Vorschläge auf den
Tisch gelegt haben die weit über das
hinausgehen was sie Umweltaktivisten
fordern sondern wir haben diese Dinge
auch bereits umgesetzt in
Regierungsverantwortung etwa mit dem
deutschlandticket die FDP gibt sich
selbstbewusst will sich innerhalb der
ampelprofilieren und lässt sich von
schwachen Umfragewerten erstmal nicht
vielleicht waren sie auch betroffen auf
Deutschlands Schienen gegen heute früh
nichts mehr es war der zweite
bundesweite Warnstreik innerhalb von
vier Wochen die Eisenbahner Gewerkschaft
EVG hatte zwischen 3 Uhr früh und 11 Uhr
morgens zum Arbeitskampf gerufen die
Passagiere waren offenbar vorbereitet
am späten Nachmittag fuhren die meisten
Züge wieder zuvor hatte die
Bahngewerkschaft EVG fast den gesamten
deutschen Schienenverkehr wie hier in
Berlin zum Berlin gebracht das Ziel der
Streikenden vor den Tarifverhandlungen
am kommenden Dienstag mit der DB aber
auch vor denen mit fast 50 weiteren
Bahnunternehmen den Druck noch einmal
spürbar zu erhöhen der Streik ist
absolut nötig weil wir jetzt in der
zweiten Verhandlungsrunde nach acht
Wochen Tarifverhandlung immer noch kein
verhandlungsfähiges Angebot haben von
allen 50 Arbeitgeber nicht die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sind absolut
sauer Bahnvorstand und EVG liegen noch
weit auseinander 12% mehr fordert die
Gewerkschaft mindestens 650 € bei 12
Monaten Laufzeit die Bahn Boot zuletzt
5% einmalig 2500 € und 27 Monate
Vertragsdauer von 3 Uhr morgens bis 11
Uhr Stillstand in den Bahnhöfen
Millionen Menschen waren gezwungen sich
andere Verkehrsmittel zu suchen
erst nervt immer kolossal also man ist
beruflich jeden Tag auf dem Zug
angewiesen und da ist immer irgendwas
entweder Filter aus er kommt es später
das wird gestreichelt man verstehen kann
man es schon irgendwo wollen ja alle
mehr Geld haben aber
ärgern tut sein trotzdem doch auch nach
streikende warnt die Bahn von
Nachwirkungen der Arbeitsniederlegungen
im Fernverkehr wird es noch bis in die
Abendstunden heute Unregelmäßigkeiten
geben aber am morgigen Samstag dürften
wir überall wieder planmäßig fahren ein
mögliches Verkehrschaos auf den Straßen
war heute vielerorts ausgeblieben
aufmachen sich die meisten Bahnreisenden
auf den Ausstand rechtzeitig eingestellt
aufarbeiten und erinnern das soll eine
von bundesinnenministerin väser
eingesetzte Kommission zum Olympia
Attentat 1972 es sei beschämend das
quälende Fragen viel zu lange offen
geblieben sein so die SPD-Politikerin am
5 september 1972 nahmen palästinensische
Terroristen Mitglieder der israelischen
Mannschaft als Geiseln bei der
Geiselnahme und der anschließend
missglückten Befreiungsaktion wurden elf
Israelis und ein Polizist getötet
Frankreichs Präsident macron steht
massiv unter Druck gegen heftige
politische und gesellschaftliche
Widerstände hat er die hochumstrittene
Rentenreform durchgesetzt der Protest
auf der Straße ist noch nicht abgeerbt
der versucht macron jetzt dagegen zu
halten mit einer Reise durchs Land im
Gesprächen mit den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern und wie das ankommt dazu mehr
jetzt von Thomas Walde
für Emanuel macron soll es ein Neubeginn
werden doch der fällt alles andere als
leicht statt sich gehört zu verschaffen
muss er sich selbst zunächst einiges
anhören
wir stimmen gar nicht mit Ihnen überein
der Rest geht im Lärm unter macron will
sich volksnah zeigen
[Musik]
sie denn bereit sind mit mir zu reden
und nicht nur Lärm machen
ein echtes Bad in der Menge ist es nicht
lauter Protest wird wie hier im
südfranzösischen Garage auf Abstand
gehalten während macron in einer Schule
zu einem bewährten Mittel französischer
Präsidenten greift sich beliebt zu
machen Geldversprechen wir müssen die
Lehrer besser wertschätzen es gibt eine
Erhöhung der Gehälter
heute kündigte die Regierung an die
Strompreise länger zu deckeln und sich
für niedrige Lebensmittelpreise
einzusetzen Geld und selfies die
Reaktion der Gewerkschaften auf diesen
Annäherungsversuch zeigt wie vielen
Misstrauen macron überwinden muss
ich denke das ist schlicht und einfach
Täuschung eine Ankündigung ohne was
dahinter wie immer und dann war da noch
das macron koordinierte mit US-Präsident
beiden telefonisch seine China Politik
nachdem er zuvor wegen eines Alleingangs
heftig kritisiert worden war sogar dies
für immer Manuel macron die Woche der
Reparaturversuche
für fast 2 Milliarden Muslime weltweit
hat heute das Fest des Fastenbrechens
begonnen es ist die große Feierlichkeit
zum Ende des Ramadans auch bei uns in
Deutschland wie hier in Osnabrück nach
vier Wochen Verzicht auf Essen Trinken
und Rauchen während des Tages kommen
jetzt viele Familien und Freunde
zusammen es gibt Geschenke für die
Kinder und großzügige Gefäß
die corona-pandemie hat viele Spuren
hinterlassen besonders auch bei Kindern
und Jugendlichen über die Folgen oder
heute im Bundestag debattiert vor allem
durch Schulschließungen haben die
seelischen Belastungen bei Kindern und
Jugendlichen deutlich zugenommen zum
Teil wirken sie bis heute nach die
Schüler haben lernrückstände entwickeln
Essstörungen kämpfen mit Einsamkeit bis
hin zu Depressionen Henriette de
Maiziere berichtet sie ringen um jeden
Buchstaben
Hausaufgabenbetreuung in der Berliner
Arche den Kindern hier oft aus sozial
schwierigen Verhältnissen stecken die
Pandemie die Folgen des lockdowns noch
in den Knochen
die haben auch nicht so viel gelernt in
der coronazeit die Aufgabe war ein
bisschen schwieriger und wenn man halt
nicht gecheckt hat dann hast Pech weil
man konnte halt niemals Fragen oder so
ich habe mich schon ein bisschen einsam
gefühlt weil ich meine Freunde nicht
sehen konnte die Arche war teilweise
geschlossen die Arche ist für die Kinder
nicht nur ein Ort des Lernens sondern
auch ihr sozialer Ort hier wird offenbar
welche Schwierigkeiten geblieben sind
manche Kinder sind übergewichtig leiden
unter psychischen Problemen und man
merkt schon dass sie nicht mehr ganz so
lebensfrohse nicht mehr ganz so viel
aktiv dabei sein wollen weil sie einfach
auch vor den Konflikten untereinander
mehr Angst haben das Mobbing hat
zugenommen Schulen geschlossen
Spielplätze gesperrt der Stillstand hat
Kinder aus sozial benachteiligten
Familien besonders getroffen
Hilfsangebote Mangelware im Bundestag
heute der Abschlussbericht der
interministeriellen Arbeitsgruppe zu den
Pandemie Folgen für Kinder mit
ernüchternden Erkenntnissen die Pandemie
ist für Kinder und Jugendliche nicht
vorbei denn die Folgen von
Schulschließungen von
kontaktbeschränkungen sie sind für sie
weiterhin deutlich zu spüren der
Gesundheitsminister räumt erneut Fehler
ein von allen die Opfer erbracht haben
in der Pandemie haben die Kinder die
meisten Opfer verbracht die Kinder haben
ältere und andere geschützt die
Maßnahmen waren zum Teil zu streng die
Schulschließungen hätte man in dieser
Länge nicht machen müssen eine Debatte
die die Gesellschaft auch künftig wird
führen müssen damit die Generation
Corona nicht abgehängt wird
und jetzt zu den Fußball
europapokalwettbewerben Norbert aus
deutscher Sicht lässt sich das im Grunde
relativ einfach zusammenfassen Bayern
raus Bayern weiter ja und Bayern könnte
von Bayern lernen nämlich siegen lernen
Leverkusen mit einem furiosen Auftritt
gestern ein besseres in der Europa
League das führte vielleicht Hinspiel
eins zu eins das Rückspiel vier zu eins
ja das stimmt einfach alles Moral
Kampfgeist Effizienz
das einzig verbliebene Bundesliga-Team
im europäischen Wettbewerb träumt vom
dritten Titel der Vereinsgeschichte das
schnelle 1:0 bei sanjiuas war der
Grundstein zum klaren Erfolg der Weg zur
Champions League in der nächsten Saison
steht Leverkusen auch über den Titel in
diesem Wettbewerb noch offen wir haben
noch die Schanze Europas für reichen es
gibt noch viele
Chanse in Europa als eine Platz zu zu
haben dabei ist erstmal noch so sehr
Mourinho mit AS Rom im Halbfinale zu
besiegen Mourinho der Alonso früher mal
trainiert hat Alonso der als Spieler 18
Titel holte nur die Europa liegt die
fehlt ihm noch für Bayer Leverkusen wäre
es der erste Titel seit 30 Jahren
der Harmonie bei Bayern Hickhack bei
Bayern nach dem Doppelhaus im Pokal und
in der Champions League hagelt es Kritik
am führungsdur kann Salihamidzic morgen
muss München in der Liga nach Mainz
wenigstens den Meistertitel will man
jetzt noch holen
zwei Titelchancen verspielt und dennoch
wird Thomas Tuchel am wenigsten dafür
verantwortlich gemacht klar er war ja
ihre Wahl wir sind total überzeugt dass
wir mit Thomas Tuchel früher oder später
wieder dort sind wo wir alle hin wollen
nämlich ganz nach oben meine
Zusammenarbeit mit mit brazo mit Olli
ist ruhig
zielorientiert
lösungsorientiert nachdem erneuten
Viertelfinale Aus in der Champions
League mehren sich Stimmen die von einer
tieferen bayern-krise sprechen jetzt
versuchen wir Deutscher Meister zu
werden und dann werden wir sicherlich in
uns gehen dann werden wir uns viele
viele Fragen stellen wir müssen uns
einfach eingestehen um diesen
Meistertitel jetzt dass wir uns dafür
nicht schämen müssen Hauptproblem die
mangelhafte Chancen Auswertung und nun
das Spiel gegen die starken Mainzer
neuen Spiele unter Boss und ungeschlagen
ein Wiedersehen von Tuchel mit einem
Schützling aus seiner Mainzer Zeit
meines gegen München morgen 15:30 Uhr
dürfte ein interessanter werden
wir bleiben beim Sport der verbindet
heißt es und wir haben ein Beispiel
dafür wie es besser nicht laufen könnte
Atem saloah 15 Jahre alt Ausnahme
Torwart mit Arminia Bielefeld bejubelt
er den ersten U17 Meistertitel der
Vereinsgeschichte erst letztes Jahr war
artem mit seiner Mutter vor dem Ukraine
Krieg geflohen jetzt träumt er von einer
Karriere hier deutsch spricht der schon
und gute Torhüter werden ja eigentlich
immer gesucht
so morgen im Osten viel Sonne im Westen
Schauer und einzelne Gewitter mehr dazu
im Wetter von Christa Orden der
ukrainische Verteidigungsminister im
heute-journal Interview mit Marietta
Slomka ab 22 Uhr schönen Dank schönen
Abend und schönen Start ins Wochenende
für Sie
[Musik]
guten Abend Herr auch die Pflanzen
reagieren jetzt auf das warme Wochenende
wie zum Beispiel die Birke denn vor
allem ihre Pollen sind im Moment in
Deutschland in hohem Maße unterwegs auch
die eschenpollen Fliegen vor allem im
Nordosten im Südwesten etwas weniger das
ganze ist für Allergiker natürlich nicht
so schön aber auch die Pflanzen nutzen
die milde Luft heute Nacht ist es am
mindestens im Westen mit 10 Grad im
Süden und im Osten ist es mit drei bis
sieben Grad kühler hier ist die Nacht
nämlich auch sternenklar Schauer und
Gewitter lassen im Süden rasch nach dann
bildet sich hier und dann Nebel die
kräftigen Gewitter von heute Abend die
sind im Westen aber noch länger
unterwegs wenn dann allerdings auch die
nachgelassen haben startet der Tag
morgen mit viel Sonne und Vorsicht die
hat schon ordentlich Kraft im
Tagesverlauf kommen von Südwesten aber
schauerartige Regen und lokal vor allem
nachmittags neue Gewitter ins Land die
der Wind aus südlichen Richtungen frisch
auf und das ganze kommt dann voran bis
zur Nordsee und bis zu den Alpen nur
ganz im Osten ist es den ganzen Tag
sonnig mit dieser sonnenunterstützung
schaffen wir es im norddeutschen
Tiefland auf über 20 Grad in der Eifel
unter den regenwalken aber gibt es nur
14 Grad und der Trend ab Sonntag ist
dann klar Schauer immer wieder Lokal
Gewitter und mit den Temperaturen geht
ist bergab auf nur noch fünf bis zehn
Grad am Dienstag das war es von uns
tschüss